so you start off brightly north is such
a great name yeah it is right great
character
how important is a name for an action
heroine how much does I don't know I
think that there is some importance to
the name but we always as soon as I
heard the name Riley North I felt like
oh my gosh that has a real ring to it
does the name ever affect how you view a
character possibly yeah I mean I it's
still this somebody just left the room
just now who said by Jenna rink and that
was my name at 13 or 13 that was the
perfect name for that character so it is
nice when they get it just right when
you join a film like this does the
character script change at all do you to
sort of suit your interests yeah I think
you know in some ways definitely you
have you know you have an opinion and
you sure conversations but pure Morel
was the director and he directed taken
and he and I were so on the same page I
would say this line feels like an action
movie cheesy line and he would like I
agree
[ __ ] and it be you know sue in that way
we were really just we wanted it to be
as grounded as possible so that we
should go as crazy as possible did
anything in particular about the
character change at all from from the
initial script I think we just deepened
the emotions that go along with being a
mom mm-hmm what was it about sort of
peppermint that made you want to sort of
join back into sort of the action feel
that there I mean to me if you're gonna
do an action movie there the the it has
to be grounded in emotion and the
emotion whatever happens has to be
strong enough that it it makes you just
where you have no choice but to fight
your no choice but to pick up a weapon
or do what you need to do and this to me
really was an expression of that mom
rage and it's a fantasy it's obviously
not not the way anyone should live but
there's something really going back to
you know Greek tragedy there's something
really satisfying about watching
somebody Express you know take control
of a situation and have some revenge was
it a conscious choice after sort of
alias and daredevil just sort of move
away from the action genre for yourself
I was having babies
it's really hard I did the kingdom when
I had a little baby in it it was its
tricky on your body so I you know my
kids are all at school I had that time
to Train so it's much more about
schedule and things like that then you
would even want to know do you ever feel
sort of typecast in any sort of
particular roles not really I'm so I
feel so lucky I do big movies little
movies action movies dramas comedies
I feel like returning to sort of stunt
work I mean what is the difference now
versus then for like fighting and doing
this stuff I think that I trained as
hard as I've trained for anything for
this film I knew what it would take I
knew that that you had to see that it
was me and it needed to be a different
style of fighting than I've done in the
past I've always kind of done it's been
martial arts-based and there have been
some pretty kicks and things like that
that really used my ballet background
this used my previous stunt background
as a starting off point and I instead
worked on boxing and Krav Maga and just
being efficient with my movement and
with fighting so that I would get in and
out as quickly as possible plus there
was a another level of artillery of
weapons training that I had ever done
before how do you say that word aren't
what's the mote what's the most
difficult training sort of process that
I do some of the weapons training was
the hardest because it was me by myself
with a group of Navy SEALs nitpicking
every single thing for eight hours a day
for days and days and days and you just
want to cry
cuz you just feel like I'm not gonna get
this right and then they do it and it
looks so effortless so in some ways that
was harder than even the physical stuff
you